-Wait a minute.
-Standing ovation!
-Did Kate Beckinsale
get a standing ovation?
-No, no, they left. They left.
They were waiting for you.
-They got popcorn in the lobby.
-Kate did get
a standing ovation.
But you, Rainn, are special
because you got one now.
-Oh, okay. Great. Great.
-Rainn, it is so great
to see you.
-It's good to see you.
-Congrats on the new book.
-Thank you so much.
-Are you excited about this?
-I am s--
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Will the book
get a standing ovation?
-Yes, the book will get
a standing ovation.
-Yeah, I worked three
and a half years on this sucker.
Yeah. I'm so excited
to release it to the world.
-I want to talk
to you about this.
But first, I wanted
to mention something
that I thought
made me happy.
Because you were
on a flight from Boston.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
From Boston to L.A.
And here's the --
Do you want to tell the story?
-I'll tell the story.
So for those who didn't see,
it was a very slow news day.
This was like
front-page news.
-It was great.
It made us feel good.
-I was on a flight
from Boston to L.A.
And so it was 5 1/2 hours
and sitting next to a gentleman
who for the entire flight
watched episodes of "The Office"
back to back to back to back.
And I was like, "What do I do?
Do I talk to him about it?
You know, how do I interact
with him about it?
You know,
should I even say anything?"
I had my COVID mask on,
so I was incognito,
and then I kind of nudged him.
-He had no idea?
-No idea the whole flight.
-The whole flight.
-Yeah. So I nudged him towards
the end, and then I was like,
"So you seem to like
that show a lot."
And he's like, "Yeah."
And I was like,
"Yeah, I heard it kind of
sucks."
And he's like,
"Well, you know, it kind of
starts slow in season one.
You got to get used to it,
but you'll warm into it."
And I was slowly, slowly,
lowering my mask like one of
those French girls, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Oh, the first
season is kind of slow, huh?"
And he's like, "Yeah."
And I was like,
"Oh, and you have to --
It takes a little while
to warm into the characters?"
And then it took him like
47 seconds of talking to me.
And then all of a sudden it was
one of those face-melting...
[ Laughter ]
...brain explosions.
-"Oh, my God!
I was sitting next to Dwight
the whole time."
-And we bonded
and it was beautiful.
-And you told him
and then you said,
"Can I post this?"
And he said yes.
-Yep, yep, yep.
-And it went uber viral.
-The rest is history.
-Yeah.
Let's just take a look at this
real quick.
-There I am.
There's the mask.
I was trying to surreptitiously
do this so he wouldn't see me.
[ Laughter ]
So I was waiting
until he was leaning forward.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-Was he eating Cap'n Crunch?
-Cap'n Crunch.
-He was eating Captain Crunch.
Yeah. Of course. Yeah.
I saw you on social media.
You have a lot
of interesting pets around.
Here's one right here.
This is a -- This is --
-That's our peahen named Alma.
[ Audience awws ]
Yeah, she's a rescue peahen.
My wife found her at her horse
stable where we keep
our pet donkey
and our pet zonkey.
[ Laughter ]
-That's where --
-You heard it here.
-Yeah, you had me at donkey
and you lost me at zonkey.
-Yeah.
-What is a zonkey?
-The spermatozoa of the zebra
enters the...
-Alright, alright, alright,
yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Hoo. Hold on.
My dad had the same talk
with me when I was a kid.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. He explained this.
I understand what's going on.
-And we've got rescue pigs.
But the thing is, is like,
I have a long, long history
of very strange pets.
-You do?
-As a child, we lived
in Nicaragua, of all places,
on coastal Nicaragua
and the Caribbean coast.
-Wow.
-Yeah. And we had a pet parrot
named Jose, and he only would
say the word Jose.
So you try and teach him other
words, you know, you'd be like,
"Hello, buenos dias, hola."
He'd be like, "Jose!"
[ Laughter ]
Morning, noon and night, Jose.
But the best was that
we had a pet sloth.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah, we found
this sloth and it was hurt.
And we put him in a nice
little sloth cage
with pillows and water
and stuff like that.
And every night he would
break out of his cage
because they're nocturnal.
Every night he would slowly,
because they move so slow,
slowly bend the bars
of his cage.
-They're strong.
-They're super strong.
And then every morning we'd
get up, and they're nocturnal.
So he's asleep when the sun
is out, and he would be gone.
But they are so slow.
My dad would be like,
"He's probably
20 or 30 feet from here."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. He didn't leave
the living room yet.
-Wandering around the yard
and literally
he'd be hanging like
in a shrub 20 feet away.
We'd go put him back
in the cage,
close the bars again,
and the same thing would happen
every single night.
-That sounds like
a kids book to me.
Yeah. The breakaway sloth.
I would read that
in two seconds.
It's a very slow breakaway.
I would read that.
-You're always thinking of a way
to cash in.
-Yeah, that's all I need
is the money.
[ Laughter ]
That's the only thing
that matters to me
until I read this book.
-Oh!
-No. This is fantastic,
by the way.
"Soul Boom."
-Yeah.
-Can we talk about what
it's about, really?
-Yeah. You know, so, you know,
the first chapter is like,
why the hell is the guy
who played
Dwight writing a book
on spirituality?
And I do have to admit
that I do kind of have
a secret inner Oprah.
And I love topics
of spirituality and mysticism
and religion.
And I think they're
really important topics.
And it's a crucial time
for us to dive
into some big spiritual ideas.
You know, the world is hurting
and spiritual tools
are there for our personal
and social transformation.
And it's an important
conversation.
-So it's not just about
religion?
-No, it's not really
about religion.
It's more about spirituality
and spiritual tools.
But I talk about, you know,
lots of big topics like life,
death, the meaning of life,
the soul, suffering, sacredness,
and by, you know,
to try and coax some
big questions out of people.
-Yeah. And it's very funny
because it's written by you.
-Yes, it's funny too.
-But it makes you think
and ask some tough questions
and has some, like,
some nice solutions to it.
One of them
I took away from this,
I was glancing through it.
One was that to just say that --
tell someone you love them
every day and that you
appreciate them.
-Yes.
-Anyone.
-The act of gratitude
has been scientifically proven
to have such
an incredible effect
on your own
personal happiness.
To express gratitude.
So to tell someone
that you love them
and to tell them something
that you're grateful to them
for will really benefit
your own happiness,
and it'll definitely
benefit theirs.
It's one simple takeaway
everyone can do
every single day.
-I love that, buddy.
That's really cool.
Congrats on this.
It's a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I also want to mention
your new series on Peacock
called "Rainn Wilson
and The Geography of Bliss."
It premieres
May 18th on Peacock.
Tell everybody
what this is about.
I'm intrigued
about this as well.
-Well, we've got a lot
of celebrities
traveling the world
and sampling delicious foods.
But I am traveling the world
looking for happiness.
-Yeah.
[ Audience awws ]
Aww!
-No, that's the reaction.
Yeah, I feel that way.
Where did you travel?
-We went to Iceland.
I went to Ghana
in West Africa.
Bulgaria.
-What'd you learn in Iceland?
-Iceland.
Oh, my gosh. Iceland.
You know, the Icelandic people
are among the world's happiest.
And there are --
-Hygge?
Hygge.
[ Laughter ]
-Hygge?
-Hygge!
-I think that's from,
like, Denmark, isn't it?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I thought it would
trigger something.
I thought -- I was waiting
for you to --
-Say it again.
-Hygge.
Yes!
That's what I'm talking about.
Yes. It's like
some way of happiness.
-It's a way of being.
-I thought it was Icelandic,
but I might be wrong.
-I think it's another
Scandinavian.
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-But they have such
an amazing connection.
The Icelanders have
an amazing connection to nature
and they love to be in nature.
They love to be naked
in nature a lot,
but they really -- like, no one
in Iceland believes in God,
but they believe -- like 80%
of them believe in fairies.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Why not?
-For real.
They believe in
little mysterious,
mystical woodland creatures.
And they're very happy.
Yeah, I learned a ton.
-This show is very interesting.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Rainn Wilson in Iceland
for "Rainn Wilson
and the Geography of Bliss."
Take a look.
-Alright. Let's do this.
-Good to see you guys.
-Oh!
-How are you feeling?
-I don't want to be this cold.
I want to drink hot chocolate,
and, um, I'm scared.
-Okay.
-It's okay.
-Your only goal now is to go
in this ocean and surrender.
But you tell your body
"I'm okay" because you,
with your nervous system
and your head,
you control everything
what your body wants to do.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
My nervous system and my hat.
Okay, good. I love it.
-Yeah. And she was right.
-Yeah.
-And she was right.
-That's right.
-Rainn Wilson, everybody.
"Soul Boom" is available
tomorrow.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Congratulations.